carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
carrusel de las artes se encuentra en
esta ocasión en el festival
internacional de cine de cannes festival
que reúne por estos días sol playa y lo
mejor del séptimo arte mundial bajo
estrictas medidas sanitarias
[Música]
conoceremos a las 24 cintas venidas del
mundo entero que aspiran a la palma de
oro a la mejor película la máxima
recompensa de este certamen en la
riviera francesa entre las estrellas en
cannes el director de cine spike el y
presidente del jurado este año un ojo
crítico y figura prominente de la lucha
contra el racismo en eeuu que se ha
colado en el afiche de esta edición
número 74 y tras un año de crisis
sanitaria vuelven también las dos
secciones paralelas del festival de
cannes la semana de la crítica y la
quincena de los realizadores dirigida
por el italiano paolo moretti nuestro
invitado en este programa
[Música]
cannes vuelve a brillar a través de su
festival internacional de cine tras un
año de silencio por causa de cubrir en
2021 las medidas sanitarias son extremas
para este evento multitudinario que
reúne a la crema y nata del séptimo arte
y de más de 5000 periodistas venidos del
mundo entero en este pequeño balneario
de la riviera francesa
cada noche promete una lluvia de
estrellas sobre la alfombra roja del
palacio de los festivales este año 24
películas compiten por la palma de oro
en este selecto grupo algunas cintas han
creado gran expectativa a continuación
lo mejor lo más destacado y lo más
glamour de esta selección 2021 3 2 1
eso es muy preciado
trión a francia presenta el número más
elevado de películas en liza por la
palma de oro siete largometrajes en
total comenzando por la cinta de
apertura de esta edición
annette del apreciado leos carax un
musical que cuenta con protagonistas de
lujo adam driver y marion cotillard
en el ramillete francés también
encontramos a we know the moon conforme
el prolífico fonso ozone y supuse bien
pase o el ganador de la palma de oro en
2015 jacques odia quien trae les o la
ampliada una historia filmada en el
barrio 13 de parís en esta lista dos
francesas detrás de las cámaras
catherine corsini con la fractura y
julia you como quien promete crear una
onda de choque en la casete con quitan
un thriller ultra violento
sin duda el elenco más glamuroso sobre
la alfombra roja de cannes es el de the
french dispatch la fantasía francesa del
muy respetado wes anderson que cuenta
con una lluvia de estrellas de hollywood
y del viejo continente desde bill murray
hasta frances mcdormand pasando por
timothée salame sabores y ronan o
benicio del toro
el italiano nanni moretti también está
en liza con tres piano al igual que john
payne en quien presenta flag day
destacamos una película filmada en
colombia memoria de apichatpong
weerasethakul quien saltó a la fama
precisamente en cannes en 2010 cuando se
llevó la palma de oro
el tailandés podría entonces alzar una
segunda estatuilla con memoria un drama
protagonizado por la camaleónica tilda
swinton
y como es tradición en cannes no podía
faltar una pizca de escándalo y ese
podría ser el rol de benedetta drama
erótico del siempre provocador paul
verhoeven sobre la pasión de una monja
por otra mujer en el siglo 17
con conjuntas realizadas tomando
la alfombra roja de cannes reunió este
año a dos figuras de lujo el actor
estadounidense adam driver y la francesa
marion cotillard y protagonistas de
annette la cinta musical de leos carax
que inauguró el festival este año y esto
fue lo que nos dijeron sus protagonistas
leos carax es uno de los más grandes
directores de cine de todos los tiempos
de inmediato le dije que sí porque amo
sus películas sus actores tienen una
libertad increíble esto lo confirme
trabajando con él cuando ejecutábamos
una coreografía milimétrica esa parte
también la disfruté mucho no hay una
buena o mala manera de hacer las cosas
es un caos controlado y él sabe
encontrar el justo equilibrio
[Música]
[Aplausos]
con la particularidad de este musical es
que a diferencia de una comedia musical
clásica la música no está pregrabada en
estudio para luego hacer playback ante
la cámara en esta película todo fue
cantado en vivo fue una preparación
distinta ya que habitualmente nuestro
cuerpo entero se focaliza en el canto y
para ello intenta no moverse mucho en
cambio en el set de annette nos movíamos
todo el tiempo entonces fue todo una
preparación física y vocal
vocal
[Música]
este año el presidente del jurado en el
festival de cannes es el director
estadounidense spike el y la primera
figura de color en recibir este
reconocimiento pero es que no es sólo
uno de los directores más agudos de
hollywood también ha tenido una larga
historia con el festival de cannes nos
amplía melissa barra
shelton jackson lee y mejor conocido
como spike lee es a sus 62 años uno de
los directores más sagaces de hollywood
director comprometido con una causa
política en especial la defensa de la
comunidad negra en eeuu desde hace tres
décadas sus películas denuncian temas de
una triste actualidad el racismo o la
violencia y discriminación contra los
afroamericanos aunque siempre con una
buena dosis de sarcasmo y humor
ingredientes que le han permitido pisar
la alfombra roja de cannes en
incontables ocasiones este año lo hará
como presidente del jurado un
reconocimiento aplazado por la crisis
sanitaria el año pasado y que el
cineasta acepto agradecido
hay un espacio muy especial en mi
corazón para parís de francia y el
festival de cannes en 1986 mi primera
película jesse fuera javi se frenó ahí
fue así que incursiones en el mundo del
cine
el afiche de la edición 64 del festival
rinde homenaje a ese primer opus sobre
la juventud negra estadounidense y la
libertad sexual allí y aparece con
grandes anteojos un accesorio que lo ha
acompañado a lo largo de su vida
en 1989 to the right thing haz lo
correcto compite por la palma de oro en
cannes una cinta visionaria en la que un
policía mata a un hombre negro
asfixiándolo
hace dos semanas celebrábamos los 32
años de to the right thing esa película
salió en 1989 y cuando ves que en
hermanos como él y que gartner
freud son asesinados hinchados veo en
ellos al personaje rai ibrahim que en la
película moría de la misma manera y me
digo cómo es que 30 malditos años
después se ve que todavía más sacan a
los negros como si fueran animales la
verdad estoy feliz de estar aquí en
cannes
elocuente crítico y humanista spike lee
ha retomado en sus películas algunos
hechos históricos como la vida de malcom
ex o cinco sangres con actores como
desde el washington o el fallecido jack
white pox band
el multipremiado lee ha dirigido 24
películas su última black landesman
sobre un policía negro infiltrado en el
ku klux klan
recibió el gran premio del jurado en la
edición 2018 del festival de cannes
en esos estados
y vino
[Música]
real
no tengan ese valor
sí
a cada año el festival de cannes se
acompaña de dos secciones paralelas la
semana de la crítica y la quincena de
los realizadores selección que busca
revelar nuevas formas de hacer cine
y tenemos cita ya mismo con el director
de la quincena de los realizadores el
italiano paolo moretti que habla muchos
idiomas entre ellos el español hola
paolo hola y aver paulo el año pasado el
festival de cannes tuvo que anularse
debido a la crisis sanitaria lo que
implicó que también las categorías
paralelas se anularán cómo se sienten
este año luego de 18 meses de volver a
reanudar con el público pues como no
sentirse muy bien como que por fin
conseguimos compartir las películas que
estuvimos buscando durante tanto tiempo
y hay unas como que vienen del año
pasado que se mezclaron que se acabaron
durante esos 18 meses y nada
tenemos muchas ganas de compartirla con
el público aquí de kant paulo y este año
en la quincena de los realizadores tres
largometrajes de américa latina que
vienen de uruguay de costa rica y de
brasil - y de siempre la quincena tiene
una atención particular para todo el
cinema el cine más moderno que se
produce en el mundo
américa latina siempre es como un
territorio de búsquedas muy avanzadas
muy sorprendentes y este año encontramos
como tres películas que con el comité de
selección tuvimos ganas de incluir en la
selección estamos muy contentos de
tenerlas con el empleado el patrón la
película medusa de anita rocha da
silveira y clara sola
de costa rica son tres películas
extremadamente diferentes entre ellas y
nada dan como tres colores de creación
diferente que existe en américa latina
no quiero decir más sobre las pelis
porque bueno es mejor descubrirlas
durante los días del festival
paolo y ustedes que reciben muchísima
película cada año como ha sido este
último año la productividad de las
películas de américa latina pero en
general con esta crisis sanitaria que
afectó a la industria del cine muchos
hicieron que como muchos rodaje pararon
y al final puede ser que ralentizaron
como tuvieron un poco de retraso pero al
final las películas se acabaron muchas
películas se quedaron así que no hubo
una reducción muy importante de película
que tuvimos que ver y al final como las
que vimos en 2020 que de que gustamos se
quedaron con nosotros fueron pídeles a
la quincena y la quincena fue fidel a
las películas así que
nada fue funcionaba así bueno muchísimas
gracias por lo moretti por habernos
recibido aquí en el cuartel general de
la quincena de los realizadores en
cannes y como se dice aquí en cannes bon
festival muchísimas gracias igualmente
así ponemos punto final este programa
especial que les presentamos desde el
festival de cine de cannes y desde ya le
damos cita para la próxima semana en
carrusel de las artes en el festival de
cine más importante del mundo
[Música]